Trascrizione: Francesca Ghizzi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera a tutti.
Nel 1950, mentre mangiava
con alcuni colleghi fisici
nella mensa del laboratorio
di Los Alamos,
Enrico Fermi improvvisamente
sollevò lo sguardo dal piatto e domandò:
'Dove sono tutti quanti?'
E non parlava degli altri commensali:
stava pensando agli extraterrestri.
Era impazzito?
No, aveva fatto un ragionamento.
Nella nostra galassia ci sono
centinaia di miliardi di stelle.
La maggior parte
sono più vecchie del nostro Sole:
le più antiche hanno 13 miliardi di anni;
il nostro Sole e la Terra
hanno 4 miliardi e mezzo di anni.
Allora, se la vita fosse apparsa
su qualche altro pianeta
attorno ad una di queste
stelle molto antiche,
quindi molto prima che sulla Terra,
potrebbero esistere nella galassia
specie intelligenti,
incredibilmente più antiche della nostra,
incredibilmente più avanzate
dal punto di vista tecnologico,
con milioni di anni
di vantaggio rispetto a noi.
Magari starebbero già
viaggiando tra le stelle.
Però noi non siamo mai stati contattati
da nessuna di queste ipotetiche
civiltà intelligenti.
Da qui la domanda di Fermi, appunto:
Dove sono tutti quanti?
È una cosa che può creare
qualche curiosità, può sconcertare.
In effetti nel corso degli anni
sono stati tentati molti approcci
per rispondere a questa domanda.
Sono state proposte
molte possibili risposte,
alcune molto fantasiose;
ma la più semplice è che
non c'è nessuno là fuori,
che siamo soli.
È possibile questo?
Credo che questa sia una domanda
che ci siamo fatti tutti quanti
prima o poi nella vita.
Io almeno me la faccio da sempre.
Quando ero bambino
guardavo un cielo stellato
e mi chiedevo se,
attorno a quei puntini luminosi
potessero esserci dei pianeti,
su quei pianeti degli esseri viventi,
che magari proprio in quel momento
stavano guardando nella mia direzione
e si stavano facendo la stessa domanda
che mi facevo anch'io.
Adesso faccio l'astrofisico.
Mi piacerebbe trovare
una risposta scientifica
a questa domanda:
'Siamo soli nell'Universo?'
Io credo veramente
che trovare evidenza che
c'è vita fuori dalla Terra
sarebbe un cambiamento epocale
per la nostra specie,
per la comprensione, anche,
del posto che occupiamo nell'Universo.
Quattro secoli fa
la rivoluzione copernicana ci ha detto
che non siamo fisicamente
al centro dell'universo.
Non c'è nessuno al centro dell'Universo,
perché non c'è un centro nell'Universo.
Un secolo e mezzo fa
Charles Darwin ci ha spiegato
che la nostra specie è imparentata
con tutte le altre specie del pianeta.
In realtà discendiamo tutti
da un unico antenato comune.
E trovare l'evidenza scientifica
dell'esistenza di altri mondi abitati,
io credo che sarebbe una terza
grande rivoluzione,
paragonabile, forse addirittura superiore
alle altre due, per portata.
Bene, negli ultimi anni abbiamo
sicuramente fatto molti passi avanti
nella direzione di una possibile risposta.
Ancora non ce l'abbiamo una risposta,
però noi siamo i primi esseri umani
ad avere le prove scientifiche
che ci sono pianeti
intorno ad altre stelle.
Questa è una delle grandi novità
dell'astrofisica degli ultimi 20 anni.
20 anni fa avremmo potuto sospettare
che ci fossero altri pianeti, là fuori;
ma adesso abbiamo le prove.
Conosciamo migliaia di pianeti
intorno ad altre stelle ormai
e ipotizziamo che, molto probabilmente,
ogni stella della nostra galassia
abbia almeno un pianeta.
Quindi stiamo parlando
di numeri giganteschi:
centinaia di miliardi
di pianeti là fuori.
Dei pianeti che conosciamo,
in realtà, sappiamo anche
che molti di loro si trovano
alla giusta distanza dalla loro stella
per avere una temperatura
che consentirebbe
la presenza di acqua liquida,
quindi di mari e di oceani,
sulla loro superficie.
E questo è uno dei requisiti
che noi riteniamo indispensabili
per la vita come la conosciamo.
Addirittura, secondo alcune
stime statistiche
potrebbero esserci, nella nostra galassia,
11 miliardi di pianeti
potenzialmente adatti alla vita.
Sottolineo il "potenzialmente" perché
stiamo veramente muovendo i primi passi,
quindi non abbiamo ancora
evidenze definitive
che uno di questi pianeti
sia effettivamente abitabile.
Però abbiamo strumenti
che li stanno studiando,
li studieranno,
e nei prossimi anni,
dalla debole luce che ci arriva
da questi mondi lontanissimi
riusciremo a capire tante cose,
a capire, per esempio,
se hanno un'atmosfera,
di che elementi è fatta
questa atmosfera,
quindi a capire se effettivamente
ci sono le condizioni
per la presenza della vita
e addirittura, in un futuro
non troppo lontano,
potremo scorgere in questa luce
delle tracce, degli indizi
che potrebbero dirci che in effetti
uno di questi pianeti
potrebbe essere abitato.
Io spero che tutti noi possiamo essere
testimoni, nell'arco della nostra vita,
di un momento del genere,
perché credo veramente che sarebbe
un cambiamento epocale per tutti noi.
Una delle domande che potremmo farci
e che spesso in realtà viene fatta è:
Li raggiungeremo mai questi altri pianeti?
E la risposta è:
Non preparate le valigie, no,
perché sono incredibilmente lontani,
sono separati da noi da un oceano
di spazio vuoto:
l'universo è veramente molto grande.
Allora vi do un esempio,
un esempio concreto.
Questa sonda alle mie spalle
è la Voyager 1.
È il veicolo spaziale costruito dall'uomo
che si è allontanato di più dalla Terra:
è in viaggio da una quarantina di anni,
è arrivata ai confini estremi
del sistema solare,
è entrata nello spazio interstellare
e si sta allontanando dal Sole
a una velocità pazzesca:
60.000 chilometri all'ora,
17 chilometri al secondo.
Quindi una velocità enorme.
Ma quanto ci metterebbe
questa sonda spaziale
per arrivare alla stella più vicina
alla nostra, Proxima Centauri,
se stesse viaggiando in quella direzione?
Ci metterebbe 74.000 anni,
che è un tempo più lungo
di quello di qualunque civiltà umana
sia esistita sul nostro pianeta.
Potremmo fare di meglio in futuro?
Certo, potremmo fare di meglio.
Ma anche la luce,
che viaggia alla velocità
massima consentita in natura,
impiega più di quattro anni
per fare questo percorso
e le altre stelle sono
incredibilmente più lontane di così.
Quindi anche semplicemente comunicare
via radio con altri sistemi,
richiederebbe centinaia o migliaia di anni
per l'invio del segnale
e la ricezione di una risposta.
Quindi è tutto molto complicato.
Forse non siamo soli nell'universo,
ma sicuramente siamo molto isolati,
siamo persi in un mare di spazio vuoto.
E allora secondo me qui c'è
una delle cose da tenere presente
quando si tenta di dare
una risposta all'interrogativo di Fermi,
che poi è l'interrogativo che
abbiamo tutti noi,
ovvero: dove sono tutti quanti?
E il fattore da tenere presente
è il tempo.
Quindi parliamo del tempo.
Uso un esempio dello scrittore
John Mcphee.
La distanza tra la punta delle dita
della mia mano sinistra
e la punta delle dita
della mia mano destra
è il tempo trascorso tra la formazione
del nostro pianeta, la Terra, e oggi:
4 miliardi e mezzo di anni.
Benissimo.
Le prime forme di vita unicellulari,
gli antenati di tutte le forme di vita
mai apparse sul nostro pianeta,
inclusi noi stessi,
compaiono abbastanza presto, qui,
da qualche parte
nel palmo della mano sinistra.
Poi questi microrganismi, batteri dominano
la vita sulla Terra per moltissimo tempo,
si replicano, si differenziano
grazie alla selezione naturale,
all'evoluzione,
e solo qui, al polso della mano destra
c'è l'esplosione delle forme
degli organismi multicellulari,
quelli più complessi, fatti da una rete
di miliardi e miliardi di cellule:
gli animali, le piante.
I dinosauri appaiono qui
alla fine del palmo della mano destra
e all'inizio dell'ultima falange
un evento naturale catastrofico,
molto probabilmente l'impatto
di un grande asteroide,
li spazza via dalla Terra
insieme a tre quarti delle specie
viventi in quel momento sul pianeta.
E di estinzioni di questo tipo,
piccole e grandi,
ci sono state moltissime volte
nel corso di questa lunga storia
della vita sulla Terra.
Addirittura si calcola
che il 99% delle specie mai vissute
su questo pianeta sono estinte.
Quindi questo ci dà un'idea
del fatto che questa lunga storia,
il cammino dell'evoluzione
della vita sulla Terra
è stato un percorso lungo,
difficile, accidentato,
governato da eventi imprevedibili,
e che quindi non doveva portare
necessariamente
all'origine degli organismi più complessi,
non doveva portare necessariamente
all'origine dell'intelligenza.
E meno che mai doveva portare
alla comparsa della nostra specie,
homo sapiens.
Ecco, noi in tutto questo dove siamo?
Bene, tutta la storia dell'umanità
sta nella punta di un'unghia.
Potremmo cancellarla completamente
con un colpo di lima.
E questo è già successo,
perché noi oggi sappiamo che
per decine di migliaia di anni
sul nostro pianeta hanno convissuto
con noi altre specie umane
che non ci sono più,
come i Neanderthal.
Allora qui forse c'è un po'
la chiave di tutto quanto.
Se un giorno, come io spero,
scopriremo che c'è altra vita
nell'universo,
è molto probabile che
si tratterà di microrganismi.
I primi extraterrestri potrebbero
essere dei semplici batteri.
La galassia potrebbe essere
dominata dai microbi.
Le specie intelligenti potrebbero
essere rarissime
e persino la loro esistenza potrebbe
essere brevissima, trascurabile
rispetto ai tempi della vita,
ai tempi dell'universo.
Magari sono le stesse
specie intelligenti,
una volta raggiunto un certo livello
di progresso tecnologico,
ad auto-annientarsi.
Oppure semplicemente
implodono, collassano, spariscono
senza lasciare nessuna
traccia nell'universo.
Allora forse questo
grande silenzio cosmico
che ci sconcerta
e ci incuriosisce,
forse è anche un po'
una specie di avvertimento,
forse ci sta dicendo qualcosa.
La vita ha dovuto superare
un gran numero di barriere
per arrivare fino a dove siamo oggi,
ma la barriera più grande
potremmo averla davanti a noi, nel futuro.
Dopo tutto pensiamo a noi stessi,
alla nostra specie da lontano,
immaginiamoci visti
da un altro pianeta.
Se noi sparissimo domani,
probabilmente nell'universo
nessuno si accorgerebbe
che ci siamo mai stati.
Siamo una specie giovanissima.
Da appena un secolo
abbiamo cominciato a volare,
a comunicare via radio.
Da una cinquantina d'anni
mandiamo sonde nello spazio.
Siamo arrivati ai confini
del sistema solare,
però, veramente, abbiamo appena
messo la punta del piede
in questo grande oceano
del cosmo che ci circonda.
Io penso che fermarci qui
sarebbe veramente un peccato.
Noi, a differenza dei dinosauri,
abbiamo, almeno in parte,
la possibilità di cambiare,
di influire sul nostro destino.
Abbiamo sicuramente la capacità
di auto-annientarci.
Però abbiamo anche,
come io credo e spero,
la possibilità di usare la conoscenza
scientifica e la tecnologia
per affrontare e superare
i problemi che ci troveremo davanti,
per garantirci un futuro lungo
in cui continuare a scoprire
cose meravigliose sull'universo,
- magari, un giorno, la vita
su qualche altro pianeta -
e chissà, magari
in un futuro lontanissimo,
perfino a raggiungere
le altre stelle.
Poi, se là fuori ci sono
delle super intelligenze galattiche,
come si vedono
nei film di fantascienza,
allora l'unica speranza
di fare parte del club
di queste intelligenze galattiche
è di sopravvivere il più
a lungo possibile: teniamo duro.
Se poi invece fossimo soli
in tutto questo spazio,
allora io credo che
ancora di più
abbiamo il dovere di mantenere accesa,
finché ci riusciamo,
questa debole, meravigliosa
fiammella di consapevolezza
apparsa per caso in un piccolo pianeta
perso nel buio del cosmo.
Grazie.
[Applausi]